meagan Markel is breaking royal rules
paving her own way across the pond
setting a precedent like never before
and is the royal family okay with it all
we are spilling the royalty hi everybody
i'm lauren zima and we have got the tea
today
our beloved megan Markel is getting
acclimated to life as a british royal
but she's also paving her own path we're
looking at all the ways megan is
breaking royal rules and making waves
across the bond see what I did there
first
Megan's been bucking tradition with her
fashion in a word pants
Markel has worked the look of paths
several times here's the thing compare
that to Kate Middleton she pretty much
never ever wears pants megan has also
swept her hair up in her now signature
messy bun look Kate's quaff is never out
of place I'm calling that the Markel
mess and it's a hot one speaking of
she's not afraid to be a little sexy
Meghan's engagement photo dress had a
deep v-neck and see-through paneling
which makes us really excited for what
her wedding dress could look like plus
when Meghan and Harry posed for these
pics wait for it guys she did not wear
pantyhose and princesses wear pantyhose
call they're so different look I want a
note I'm not saying who's right and
wrong here because Kate Middleton is a
goddess among peons and she works
pantyhose and pretty dresses like no
other I love them both but Meghan is
definitely doing things differently and
hey the monarchy was probably due for a
little shake-up as royal expert Katie
Nichol tells us the general impression
I'm getting from the people on the
streets is that she's a breath of fresh
air she's going to help to rejuvenate
the royal family it's not just with
fashion guys Meghan has also signed
autographs and that may seem small but
it's something the Royals never do
reportedly so that they don't risk their
signatures being forged Plus Meghan and
Harry whoa hold hands
and practice some adorable PDA something
will and Kate refrain from utterly
unprecedented role behavior usually we
don't see those public displays of
affection plus we've heard that Megan
wants to give a toast at her own wedding
which royal Brides typically do not do
it all seems a little weird right like
shouldn't a bride be able to speak at
her own wedding but this is why we love
Megan the Royal Way of life is beautiful
in its traditions but Megan is given it
a little update we can sometimes be a
bit buttoned up and a little bit stiff
and she's gonna cover it in blow all of
that away and perhaps the most
significant and powerful way Megan is
changing things up at her first official
royal public appearance with Harry will
Aunt Kate she spoke out about women's
movements right now in the climate that
we're seeing with so many campaigns I
mean with me too when times up Royals
are supposed to stay out of politics so
that was a big move but let's remember
another woman who dared to be different
and became an icon so the big question
how does the royal family feel about all
of Megan's mountain-moving in short they
seem on board
megan has been getting close with
Harry's family the family together being
absolutely no sort of support and my
grandparents as well and they even had
her spend Christmas with them when she
and Harry were just engaged this is a
break from tradition Plus guys our girl
has fallen in line in many ways okay
she's moving to another country for
Harry she's quitting acting and et has
learned if she even just got baptized
ahead of their wedding in May how much
more can she do what do you want what do
you want we want you Megan exactly as
you are so what do you guys think of our
American princess shaking things up in
jolly old England let me know thanks so
much for watching and see you next week
cheerio
[Music]